les trois bâtiments de l'ancienne
menuiserie n'ont pas résisté aux flammes
au total 650 mètres carrés sont partis
en fumée
le feu aurait pris au petit matin à 5h30
du matin j'ai entendu du bruit dehors
et en regardant j'ai vu le feu qui était
dans le local j'ai appelé immédiatement
les pompiers
pas de blessé mais les dégâts matériels
sont importants
une des maisons jouxtant la menuiserie
désaffecté a été partiellement détruite
mais la solidarité a joué à plein amis
et famille des sinistrés ont aidés pour
assurer le relogement
au total une trentaine de pompiers a
participé aux opérations
une intervention rendue délicate en
raison de l'important stock de bois
présents dans la menuiserie et la
proximité des habitations
il était confronté à plusieurs feux
puisque nous sommes sur un site où il ya
trois bâtiments 3 4 bâtiments à accoler
et donc il ya une propagation qui s'est
fait de l' incendie
ce qui fait qu'il fallait intervenir sur
plusieurs fronts en même temps pour
pouvoir limiter sa propagation sur
d'autres bâtiments et notamment pas bio
on ignore pour l'instant les causes de
cet incendie
la gendarmerie a ouvert une enquête